pens up let's let's draw a diagram okay
a smooth circular cone okay i'm going to
draw it like this
okay um you don't know where it ends
they don't tell you how tall it is
it doesn't matter though because it's
all pretty consistent
there's my cone vertex up
axis
is vertical okay so there you go facing
upwards is not at an angle
it has a semi vertical angle of 60
degrees uh we know what semi means right
semi think about like conics semi just
means half right like semicircle
okay so the semi vertical angle of 60
degrees is in there
okay a particle of mass one kilogram
mass mass
one kilogram is attached by a light
inelastic stream
from a point vertically above the vertex
of the cone so i'll call that c
up there p moves with constant
speed v meters per second
so that's a linear speed isn't it it's
not an angular speed because it's
meters per second not radians per second
v
means per second on the outer surface of
the cone
in a horizontal circle okay so it's
sitting on top of this cone
and it traces out this this
circular path here okay so let me throw
that in
that's pretty awful but you get the
picture all right so there's p
over there okay it's moving around and
that horizontal circle
has a radius of 0.5 meters so
here is the center of the horizontal
circle i guess we'll call that o
okay and that radius there
0.5 meters
the string makes an angle of 30 degrees
with the vertical so we already
worked out where the vertical is it
lines up with the axis of the cone
30 degrees okay
so then there are a few questions um
and i'll leave this guide here okay part
a
can we get a horizontal force
and a vertical force there's the first
question
second question if we know what the
velocity is let's call it one
meter per second okay find the magnitude
of the tension in the string
and the reaction force
on the cone of the cone on p i'll talk
about that in a second
of cones on the peak
last question um i'll read it to you
find the maximum value of v find how
fast you can go
that lets p maintain contact with the
code
find the maximum value v that lets p
maintain contact with the code okay you
now know this right
we looked at this we just derived this
example okay if i increase v
enough right right now it's on the
surface of my imaginary cone there but
if i increase v
it'll lift off okay does that make sense
so there's clearly some upper limit on
what that velocity is we want to try and
find that
okay so maximum
v to remain on current
question mark okay have a go
start off remember we've already started
our diagram but there are no forces on
it yet
okay so why don't you put all the forces
there use colors if you can because it
really helps you distinguish all of them
and then i'll give you a couple minutes
head start and then i'll do it
so the first easy bit is your gravity no
problems okay
it's mg but you know that the mass is
just one so i put the one there just
kind of
for completeness set okay so there's
gravity going down
then you've got tension going up along
the string so far so good
so you've got a vertical component
you've got a horizontal button has
anyone worked out what those are yet
can you work out what they're done okay
have a look let's just do it quickly now
okay
you've got um this angle in here
right so you can work out what this is
through the same trig sort of thing that
we worked out before
okay i'm pretty sure it's going to be
you have 30 degrees here right
so you want this and it's the adjacent
side so it's going to be t cos theta
is that okay i know you know what cos 30
is but i'm just showing you that so you
can see where i got it from
same deal you're going to get t sine 30
going in the horizontal direction so
just
squeeze that in okay now i've accounted
for two
forces right and i've resolved them up
down left right
okay but there's a force i'm missing
there's a force i'm missing
okay now it's easy to illustrate
if i show you something like this okay
so
you've got an object and it's resting on
a surface okay now at least at the
moment
it's not going anywhere right so you've
got gravity going down
and then you've got reaction force going
up
and that's why it stays pushed okay ah
but now
if i tilt this right so i'll move this
up here
if i put this at an angle like this
well it slides off wait what happened
why did it slide off
i wasn't i wasn't i wasn't pushing it or
anything what was exerting force in
another direction to make it move
because we know
because of inertia if there wasn't some
force making it move it would
stay put why when i tilted it
did it well sorry floppy board did it go
from its stable position
to its unstable position
why why this is all i did i just tilted
it like that
and the answer is right the reaction
force that's being exerted by this book
it will exert only in one particular
direction namely
whatever direction the surface is facing
in now right now
that surface is exactly opposite facing
to gravity
directly up but the second it's not
directly facing gravity if i go off like
this
okay now it's facing well where's it
facing
um it's facing off in that direction
okay so it's exerting some force that
way which is why the keys slide off that
way
does that make sense so to summarize
this current this is the difference
between you know magical thing floating
out in mid-air
or it's sitting on a cone the cone is
exerting its own
force its reaction force and it's going
perpendicular perpendicular
to the surface of the cone just like it
was going perpendicular
to the surface of the book okay so i've
got this tension going up this way
and then i've got the cone going off
that way
okay now because it's perpendicular
rather than call it the
reaction force which is a bit generic
okay we'll call it
n n for normal okay so i've got n
going this way all right so now
more colors what force is n exerting
horizontally and vertically let's have a
look uh
it's got a it's got a vertical component
right
i can see it like this
up like that have a look at the
horizontal component
it's not taking it toward the center
it's taking you away from the center
why is it doing that why would it be
pushing you away from the center
what would happen if it wasn't pushing
away from the center
the the thing would just go straight
into the cone right
but it's not it's pushing back it's like
no no you stay on your circular path out
there
so these two right they're pushing out
okay so you've got these two forces let
me um
let me save you a bit of time i'm going
to put my piece of it
underneath let me save you a bit of time
and tell you what those forces
are you got a vertical force here of
oops sorry that's not clear
goodbye people who have to go thank you
okay um where am i
oh right okay you got n cos
60 here and n sine
60 there okay you can go ahead and you
can double check the triangles
okay all right
finally i've got a diagram it's got all
the forces on there i used trigonometry
to work out
what all these sizes were all of the
different bits right
i started to resolve but i'm not
finished right i know
what they're equal to when i add
everything up okay so let's do
vertically first because it's boring
vertically what kind of motion is there
it's a horizontal circle so vertically
it's not going anywhere
okay so if i add up all of these up down
forces they should all
sum to zero right okay
so i've got let's see here these ones
are going up these ones are going down
so they should oppose each other
so i've got t cause ooh i switched these
around
hold on sorry
very clean that's right
i know i have i have some triangle as
well
i think this should be oh no no it's
okay
yeah no no no i'll write the first place
it's okay um you can look at it from
other triangles point of view but you
get i think
it costs 30 just the same thing or
cos 60. it's just looking at it from a
different triangle anyway
ah where am i i've got this um t cos
30 and n sine 60
they're going up and then you've got
gravity going down
is that all right okay so i know what
both of these are they're both
root three and two okay so i'm going to
save myself a bit of time
and just divide everything through by
root three and two which gives me
two g on root three is that all right
equation one which i got from vertical
okay horizontally what's going on
horizontally i have uniform circular
motion
so these two forces which are going in
opposite directions right so there's
going to be
i'm going to say a plus in this way and
a minus out that way because i'm heading
back towards the center that's my
my default view okay they should add up
to m
r omega squared right so you're going to
get this
30. so i'm calling positive by the way
in towards the center because that's my
default mode
okay maybe i should put that in positive
okay so t sine 30 minus n
cos 60 because that's the normal force
pushing out
okay now i could call it i could call it
m r omega square but it turns out that's
not such a useful way to phrase it
in this situation why not
because i don't know anything about
angular velocity right i only know
linear
right so instead of m r and e squared
what was our alternative in terms of v
and v squared on r right
okay so i'm going to do that instead m
v squared on r okay
all right now i know what m is
right it's just one i know what the
radius is
it's uh it's a half isn't it uh-huh
great and i know what these are they're
both going to be equal to a half as well
okay so far so good so i'm going to
multiply everything by
two that will get rid of these guys
should put this guy up
save you a bit of time here's what you
get are you content with that
so i've divided by half here and then
i've multiplied by two from here
okay equation two
well done that's that right
that's that's what i got from there i
have my
vertical and my horizontal forces now
all resolved out
okay including um gravity and
the tension and the normal that's coming
from the current